so I want to talk about wheat there's a
book it's a great book called the wheat
belly
it's a New York Times bestseller and
this is what it says on the back did you
know that eating two slices of a
whole-wheat bread can increase your
blood sugar more than two tablespoons of
pure sugarcane well what happens is that
wheat is probably the number one culprit
destroying more bodies than anything
that I know about including sugar the
protein we called gluten is can act like
a microbe and that protein can create
anything from celiac disease which is
the digestive thing can destroy your
intestines to Crohn's which is another
digestive problem all the itis ins
inflammation of arthritis bursitis
tendinitis psoriasis skin problems
everything from allergies to ad DS to
hyperactivity massive blood sugar
problems diabetes
that's what wheat causes yeah it's
probably a food that on almost plates
especially in the morning so and I'm
talking about breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits waffles pancakes those
right there not that you eat those but
you'd probably know people who do so
wheat has been destroyed as far as the
the grain itself in America long ago we
had in other countries but we imported
or exported from it was very high in
protein and now they modified it and
they heightened did hybrids to make it
very hard high in carbohydrates to make
it easy to put in dough to make all
sorts of flour and pastries and things
like that so we really change that
product starting out as being a good
product to a very unhealthy product and
I think our bodies have rejected it by
creating allergies and inflammation so
all those symptoms are a way of your
body trying to tell you don't eat it now
grain is the seed of a grass okay so in
that seed what we do is we grind it down
into flour that's what we make
breads pasta cereal crackers and
biscuits and things like that from if we
exposed the grain to oxygen you destroy
a lot of the nutrients in fact pretty
much everything within six days most the
flour on the Shelf has been sitting on
there for months and months now if we
take it on the other side to white bread
what they did is they put bleach in it
and bleach like that's like pretty toxic
to the pancreas there's been studies to
show that when you put bleach in flour
and you feed it to animals they get
diabetes so what they do is they spray
some synthetic vitamins and tell you
that's fortified but it's all synthetic
okay so when you consume refined flour
you can end up depleting those original
nutrients that were supposed to be in
there so that's what happens so if if
flour normally had potassium or B
vitamins then you would create a B
vitamin and potassium deficiency as you
eat that food I remember when I got
married we went out to shop for for
these cakes for the wedding and don't
ask me why but we started shopping and
eating all these cakes all day long and
I'm going what are we doing we're just
gonna we're gonna have like a major
blood sugar so it was just flour and
water all day long and then we end up at
a Italian restaurant and I consumed
massive quantities of pizza and pasta
and bread all this refined flour when I
went to bed that night I couldn't even
sleep because I felt my pulse just
pounding in my ear boom boom boom boom
the heart was working harder that was a
potassium deficiency so I literally
created a potassium deficiency by
consuming that type of food it took me a
couple days to kind of put the potassium
back so it can be very depleting with
potassium and the B vitamins which are
designed to actually help your heart
okay so if you take grain and you sprout
it like an Ezekiel bread or a sprouted
bread it's much much better okay because
it's higher in protein but most breads
out there are
very very high glycemic so they turn the
sugar very rapidly so wheat has the
capacity to either kill you or create
disease or it has the capacity to heal
you depending on the form that it's in
so recently I was very interested in
searching out for something to align
with my principle of getting people
healthy and I knew that that comes from
food so I asked my question asked a
question what food has the highest
nutrition so I started looking into what
what we could use even in my own clinic
to heal people faster and believe it or
not I found wheatgrass is incredible as
far as the nutrient density in there and
specifically request Juice and Whitmore
had clinics cancer clinics for years and
she wrote a book on how wheatgrass can
really heal your body and she talked
about her success with diabetes and
ulcers and people that are really sick
so it's very interested in getting some
wheatgrass so what I did is I I started
buying different samples of wheatgrass
and they have two different kinds
wheatgrass powder and wheatgrass juice
powder the difference is the juice
powder is very very concentrated so I
started trying this out and I found a
company that really impressed me and
what they did was they grew the
wheatgrass on a different type of soil a
soil that was over the salt beds in Utah
where they had the ancient seabeds where
they had all the sea minerals from the
sea salt minerals so that gave that the
wheatgrass a chance to pull from the
earth all the 74 trace minerals that it
needed so I started giving it to my
staff and including myself and I was
just amazed how how fast it worked and
how good it made you feel I mean you
will not need coffee when you when you
drink this stuff or when you put it in
water so the reason why it's so healthy
is that when you take aggressive grain
and you start sprouting and
to a little grass you release 1,400
times the nutrition then the actual seed
contained so check this out these are
two types of wheatgrass juice powder one
is grown on very very healthy soils and
the other one is grown on soils that are
not really that great and you can see
the difference between color and texture
the one that's very nutrient dense is
dark green when you drink this you're
going to get a lot more nutrition
because you don't lose any of the
nutrition and you get all the trace
minerals now one teaspoon of raw
wheatgrass juice powder is equivalent to
one and a half pounds of organic
vegetables so it is super concentrated
it's like drinking liquid sunshine so
here we have the the grain of the
wheatgrass which actually causes disease
terrible disease terrible obesity and
over here we have the grass of the grain
which has been known to cure disease
help you lose weight and get you
incredibly healthy fascinating so here's
what I recommend if you want to try some
only take one teaspoon a day in the
morning not before you go to sleep
because you're not going to be able to
sleep you're gonna find that you're not
going to need coffee when you take this
but take one teaspoon in in the morning
and I would recommend either putting in
water and mixing it up and dissolving it
or putting it in your kale shake that
your you should be taking right now and
that way you will add an additional one
and a half pounds of vegetables the
nutrition of that many vegetables in a
very small container